Transcriber: Zeinab Alnayal
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
السيد “عادي”
والسيدة “عاديَّة”
يلتحقان بالمدرسة
وينهيان 12 عاماً من الدراسة ليحصلا
على شهادة إنهاء المرحلة الثانوية.
يحصلان على مجموع يبقى للمقارنة لاحقاً.
ويبدآن المفاضلة على مقاعد الجامعة لأنه يجب
عليهما الدخول إلى الجامعة والدراسة
لكي يتمكنا من العمل.
يتخرجان، ويقدمان على أول فرصة وظيفية
ليبدآ مشوراهما المهني،
فتبدأ المفاجآت.
هما بحاجة لكتابة CV أو السيرة الذاتية،
والتي تبدأ عادةً بالمعلومات الشخصية، مثلاً
الاسم، تاريخ الميلاد، معلومات التواصل
رقم الجوال، البريد الإلكتروني، ثم يأتي
ذلك القسم المهم المؤهل العلمي (الأكاديمي)،
وعادةً نظن أن هذا المؤهل يجب أن يتوافق مع
الفرصة الوظيفية أو العمل الذي نقدم عليه.
فلننظر معاً إلى بعض الأرقام.
ضمن المخطط أمامكم، وهو عبارة
عن فيديو نجد 4 منحنيات
والتي تمثل فئة الشباب
الذين تتراوح أعمارهم بين 25 سنة أو أكثر،
يمثل المحني البنفسجي ضمن الفيديو الأشخاص
ذوي أعلى تحصيل علمي ضمن الفئة المدروسة،
حصلوا على درجة البكاولوريوس،
ما يعادل دراسة 4 أو 5 سنوات.
كلما كانت القيمة أكبر ضمن المنحني،
كلما زاد معدل البطالة
بقراءة سريعة نستنتج أنه حتى
في 2020، في زمن الكورونا
لم يكن هؤلاء الأشخاص عرضة
لفقد عملهم كغيرهم.
ضمن دراسات ومراجع
من مصادر أخرى سنجد نفس الفكرة،
وهي أنك كلما تعلمت أكثر كلما حصلت على فرصة
عمل أفضل أو أنك تتجنب البطالة عموماً.
أي أن الوالد أو الوالدة لدى قولهما:
“ابني! ابنتي! إدرسا!” لم يكونا مخطئين!
لكن ...
في دراسة أخرى قام بها أيبل وديتز.
وفي جدول يشرح نتائج الدراسة ضمن اتجاهين،
الاتجاه الأول: لدينا هنا مجال واسع
إذا درست الهندسة الميكانيكية، أكون قد درست
ضمن هذا المجال وسأحصل على إجازة فيه،
وإذا درست ضمن  الهندسة
الميكانيكية هندسة الطيران
سأحصل على إجازة في الهندسة
الميكانيكية ضمن اختصاص هندسة الطيران.
تستطيعون تعميم هذا المثال
على أكثر من اختصاص.
ضمن هذه الدراسة اكتشفوا أن 38%
من الأشخاص يعملون خارج مجالهم العام،
وحوالي 73% يعملون خارج اختصاصهم.
سؤال: كم شخص هنا يعمل أو يتدرب
خارج اختصاصه أو مجاله؟
جميل! هذا الخطاب موجه لكم وسترون فيما بعد
أن الخطاب موجه أيضاً للذين لم يرفعوا أيدهم
وفي خبر آخر من Business Insider
نشر عام 2019 يقول:
أن غوغل لم تعد تشترط عند توظيف الأشخاص
وجود شهادة البكالوريوس،
ستوفر لهم راتباً أعلى لكن لا تعتبر شرطاً،
في حين تشترط وجود المهارة والخبرة.
أكيو موريتا، وهو المؤسس الشريك لشركة سوني
لديه اقتباس مشهور يقول فيه:
“لدينا قاعدة في الشركة، عندما نوظف شخصاً
ما فإننا لن ننظر في سجلاتهم الدراسية
ولن يتم الاعتماد عليها مستقبلاً من أجل
التقييم أو من أجل الترقية الوظيفية”
لا بد أنكم تتساءلون أن تعب سنين
الجامعة ذهب هباءً، أليس كذلك؟
من حقكم التساؤل!
لا، قطعاً لا! ليس هذا منطقياً.
أعتذر عن كثرة ذكري للدراسات،
فقد بقيت فكرة هنا.
حيث توجد مهارات نحصل
عليها من الجامعة ولا نلقي لها بالاً.
هذه المهارات موجودة ضمن دراسة
أجراها أكريبيرت عام 2015
بالمقابل، يمكنكم أن تبحثوا في فوربز
وإيميريتيس، وأن تقاطعوا هذه المهارات
والموجودة بمسميات مختلفة في فوربز مع
المهارات المطلوبة في سوق العمل.
هذا يعني أنّنا أمام طيف
واسع من مهارات العمل التي نملكها.
فلنواجه الواقع. لن نستفيد من كل شيء أخذناه
في الجامعة بعد التخرج مباشرةً،
ومن الممكن ألّا نستفيد من بعض الأمور أبداً
وبالمقابل، هناك أمور مهمة لا ننتبه لها
ممكن أن تعطينا فرصاً أقوى للحصول على عمل،
أو أن تساعدنا في تأسيس مشروعنا الخاص.
سنأخذ مثالاً سريعاً.
من منكم تعلَّم المناظرة؟
قد تتساءلون ما فائدة المناظرة؟
دعوني أحدثكم عن فائدتها من وجهة نظر شخصية.
إن تعلمتها فكأني تعلمت التفكير الاستراتيجي
في الشطرنج، وكأنني أيضاً ألعب تنس الطاولة.
كيف ذلك؟ لأنه في المناظرة
نتعلم أن نخطط قُدماً، أي أننا نُحضِّر ملف
المناظرة، ونُحضِّر حججنا ونتنبأ بحجج الخصم
في ذات الوقت وغالباً في كل مناظرة يقوم
الخصم بتحضير أمور لم نتنبأ بها،
عليّ التفاعل معها بسرعة وأضرب بقوة كما في
لعبة تنس الطاولة كي أحصل على النقطة.
ومن الأمور المهمة أيضاً في المناظرة،
هو أن نتعلم سماع الطرف الآخر حتى النهاية،
حيث أن المناظرة تعتبر جدلاً منظم.
وأجمل ما في المناظرة أننا أحياناً نتبنى
وجهة نظر تُعاكس وجهة نظرنا الشخصية.
أي أننا نُفكِّر كما يُفكِّر الطرف الآخر.
إن أخذنا هذه المهارات وحلَّلناها سنجدها
مفيدة ولها استخدامات في سياقات أخرى.
يمكننا تطبيق نفس طريقة التحليل السابقة
على طيف واسع من الأمور الأخرى.
إن كنت ألعب كرة القدم أو السلة وهي رياضة
جماعية، فأنا أتعلم مهارة العمل ضمن فريق.
وإن كنت كابتن الفريق، فلديّ مهارات قيادية.
إن كنت كاتباً للشعر أو النثر، فلديَّ قدرة
على الصياغة اللغوية الجيدة.
فلي أن أتجه إلى تعلم كتابة المحتوى
على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي.
إن كنت رساماً، فلديّ تصوّر جيّد للأبعاد
(الهندسة أو الفنون الجميلة).
وحيث أني ذكرت الفنون الجميلة، فإن طلابها
وطلاب الهندسة المعمارية
يتعلمون ضمن الجامعة شراء مجموعة
من المواد واستخدامها بطريقة موفرة.
إن بحثنا عن هذا المبدأ فسنجد أنه قريب جداً
من مصطلح إدارة اللوجستيات.
وإن بحثنا على الإنترنت فسنجد فرصاً وظيفية
تحت مسمى Logistics Officer
أو مسؤول اللوجستيات.
وإن كنت متطوعاً في الكشاف،
هذا يعني أنني أقوم بالتخييم،
أي أنني أمتلك الجلد والصبر،
ولديّ قدرة تحمل أكبر للعمل الميداني.
الكشاف يعني التطوع، وبما أنني أذكر التطوع،
سنتعلم عدة مهارات وخبرات فقط إن خصصنا بعض
الوقت من أجل المبادرة أو الجمعية الفلانية،
أو مثلاً قررنا أن ننظّم فعالية تيد إكس!
كل ما أود قوله هنا هو أن تخصصوا 30 ثانية
أو حتى 10 فقط للتفكير بالمهارات
التي حصلتم عليها من اختصاصكم أو من معرفتكم
والتي يمكن أن تفيدكم ضمن اختصاصكم وخارجه.
هذه المهارات عُرفاً موجودة ضمن
الدراسات الأكاديمية بمسمى:
المهارات متعددة الأبعاد
Multi-dimensional Skills.
الأمر ليس متوقفاً على ما نملكه،
فنحن بحاجة تعلم ما هو جديد أيضاً.
ليس بإمكاننا إيقاف رحلة التعلم.
إن اللحظة التي نوقف فيها رحلة تعلمنا
في الحياة هي اللحظة التي نقرر فيها أن نموت
فلنسأل العم جوجل إن كنت أريد تعلم
شيء جديد فكم يلزمني من الوقت؟
ضمن أول نتيجة بحث ظهرت لي كان الجواب
أني بحاجة إلى 6 أشهر على الأكثر،
وضمن ثاني أو ثالث نتيجة بحث والتي كانت
غريبة نوعاً ما حيث كانت 20 ساعة،
وبعدها يمكنني إدراج
المهارة ضمن السيرة الذاتية.
هذا لا يعني هذا أنني
أتقنت المهارة بشكل كامل!
لا، بمثال واقعي: مايك شييك،
يمتلك قناة على اليوتيوب،
قرر أن يتعلم 41 مهارة ضمن سنة واحدة فقط!
وبعد عام واحد!
قام بمراجعة المهارات
التي تعلمها ضمن فيديو آخر!
ووجد أنه قادر على تنفيذ هذه المهارات
على درجات متفاوتة دون أن ينساها.
ففي النهاية، أمضى عاماً في تعلم 41 مهارة!
أي أنّه أمضى وقت جيد في التدريب!
يمعنى آخر، نحن نمتل
القدرة على تعلّم أي شي جديد.
لدينا القدرة على تعلم أمور ضمن اختصاصنا
وخارجه، بل ونستطيع النجاح خارج اختصاصنا!
مثل ديفيد إيجلمان، الحائز على إجازة
في الأدب الإنجليزي والأميريكي
وبعدها حصل على الدكتوراه
في اختصاص علوم الأعصاب!
قد تقولون أن هذا بسبب أنه أجنبي وأنه يعتبر
أمراً عادياً لمن يعيشون في الخارج.
في الصورة، الكابتن عليا الياسين
اختصاصها الجامعي في الأصل هو هندسة
الكهرباء ولكنها لا تعمل ضمن اختصاصها!
وهي أول محكم دولي يترأس طاقم تحكيم
لكرة السلة في الوطن العربي.
لم يمر على عودتها من آخر
بطولة سوى بضعة أيام.
والمثال الأشهر في مجال تعدد المواهب
هو ليوناردو دافينشي.
فهو مفكر وفيلسوف ونحات ورسام، بل ومهندس
ستقولون ...
هذا ليوناردو! إنه نابغة!
هو مولود هكذا بحزمة جينات جاهزة
وأن البيئة المحيطة به عظيمة جداً!
فلنناقش فكرة الجينات، أو أن أحداً ما قد
يكون نابغة هكذا بكل بساطة!
تجربة بولغار - لازلو بولغار -
في صناعة بطلات الشطرنج
نبذة سريعة.
لازلو بولغار لديه 3 بنات.
قرر أن يصنع منهن بطلات شطرنج.
خصص لهنَّ برنامجاً من تصميمه لإمضاء
أكبر وقت ممكن في التدرب.
النتيجة الأولى أن أصغر بناته
وبعمر 4 سنوات فقط
انضمت إلى نادي الشطرنج المحلي
وتحدت جميع اللاعبين بمن فيهم الأساتذة
والذين خسروا جميعاً!
بعمر 4 سنوات فقط!
كي أكون صادقاً معكم بنسبة 100%
لا توجد أي دراسة أكاديمية تقول أن تجربة
بولغار مثبتة بنسبة 100%.
لكنني لم أقف أيضاً على أي دراسة
تنفيها بشكل كامل!
أي أن تجربة بولغار قابلة للتعميم
ولو ببعض أجزائها على الأقل.
أي أن العبقرية تُصنع.
وأنتم تستطيعون أيضاً أن تكونوالعباقرة!
ما أودُّ قوله لكم اليوم،
أننا من كثرة حلِّنا لمسائل الرياضيات حصلنا
على مهارة التحليل المنطقي دون انتباهنا!
بإمكاننا النجاح ضمن وخارج اختصاصنا.
يوجد أشخاص يسمعونني الآن هم رائعون
ولديهم هذه الأمور بالفعل.
لستم بحاجة الفيتامين واو بقدر احتياجكم
للجلوس مع بعضكم أو مع أنفسكم،
وأن تسألوا أنفسكم: ما مدى أهمية المعدل
في الثانوية؟ فلتنسوا هذا الرقم قليلاً!
لديَّ مهارات ومعارف متمكن منها
أو بحاجة لتقويتها
وفي ذات الوقت لديّ أحتاج أو
أرغب بتعلم مهارات جديدة.
عزيزي مسؤول الموارد البشرية
أو مسؤول التوظيف إن كنت تسمعني في مكان ما،
نحن جميعاً لسنا مجرد اختصاص،
فالعالم متجه نحو الاختصاصات الهجينة.
نحن مجموعة قصص موجودة في ذات المكان،
ويمكننا إضافة المزيد
والمزيد! وشكراً لكم.